مازن اخر تطورات في كوبيانسك بعد محاولات
التقدم فيها من خلال القوات الروسيه
نعم ازدهار في الواقع مدينه كوبيانسك في
عين العاصفه عمليه وضمن مدى الهجوم الروسي
المضاد اذا ما صح التوصيف بعد شهرين ونصف
من الهجوم الاوكراني يبدو ان زمام
المبادره تحديدا في خركيف وفي هذه المنطقه
في كومبياس استعادتها القوات الروسيه التي
تضغط باتجاه هذه المدينه انا اقف عمليا
وحاليا الان في وسط المدينه هذا المركز
الاداري الرسمي في مدينه كوبيانس وكان قد
تعرض سابقا لقصف ولكن خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه تم استهدافه بوابل من الصواريخ
ويجري الحديث هنا عن ان الطائرات روسيه
القت بصاروخ باتجاه هذا المبنى تحديدا
الذي كان يشكل رمز السياده الاوكرانيه على
هذه البلده التي باتت تقع الان عند خط
المواجهه يمكن ان نشاهد عمليا حجم الدمار
الذي لحق بكل هذه المنطقه ليس فقط في وسط
ولكن ايضا في مستويات متعدده من هذه
المدينه التي تبعد عن الحدود الروسيه نحو
20 كيلومترا ولكنها اليوم تبعد ثمانيه
كيلومترات عن خط المواجهه الاول الذي يمكن
ان نشاهده في الافق عمليا ضمن هذا المسار
هذا الافق الطويل في تلك المنطقه هنالك
مواجهات حاميه الوطيس ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه الذي يحصل
محاولات للتقدم يمكن ان نشاهد وسط البلده
يبدو شبه خالي من السكان عمليا اعداد
قليله جدا من السكان تتواجد في المدينه
وتحاول ان تدبر امورها ولكن خط المواجهه
الذي يظهر في الافق هناك تحصل اشد
المواجهات قبل قليل كنا نرصد القذائف وهي
تنطلق وراجمات الصواريخ من جهه الى جهه
اخرى عمليا لا تبعد خطوط المواجهه بين
الطرفين سوى بضعه كيلومترات
يحاول القوات الروسيه التقدم باتجاه هذه
المدينه التي تعتبر مدينه استراتيجيه
استعادتها القوات الاوكرانيه في سبتمبر
الماضيه عندما نفذت هجومها الكبير
لاستعاده اجزاء واسعه من
لماذا كوبيانسك لان القوات الروسيه تحاول
عمليا التقدم باتجاه هذه المنطقه لسببين
السبب الاول هو تخفيف الضغط الذي تتعرض له
القوات الروسيه على اكثر من محور في شرق
البلاد في تحديدا وهي اختارت هذه المنطقه
من خلالها يمكن ان تتقدم لانها نقطه تقاطع
ما بين جبهتين ومحورين
مقاطعه لوغان ومقاطعه هي تريد ان تؤمن
اولا خط الدعم لكل مقاتليها المتواجدين في
لوغاس والدفع بهم بهذا الاتجاه لمحاوله
السيطره على مدينه كوبيانسك التي تلعب
دورا كبيرا وهاما واستراتيجيا اذا ما وصلت
اليها القوات الروسيه
قبل قليل كنت اتحدث مع عمده المدينه كان
يقول بان كل المحاولات الاوكرانيه الان هي
للاستماته للدفاع عن هذه المدينه لان
سقوطها يحمل بعدين بعد رمزي بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه التي كانت قد استعادت
هذه المدينه مع الافع الكيلومترات هنا في
هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه هنالك خشيه
من ان تؤدي سقوط هذه المدينه بيد القوات
الروسيه الى متغير على مستوى خط الجبهه
ليس فقط في خركان ولكن كانت داعيات محتمله
تطال كل الجبهه الشرقيه التي يتواجد فيها
هذا هو حال المدينه يمكن ان نشاهد حجم
الدمار ليس فقط في هذه الاماكن ولكنه
ينتشر في اماكن متعدده والمدينه شبه خاليه
من سكانها صحيح ان كان هنالك عمليات اخلاء
ولكن ليس فقط من كوبي ولكن من كل البلدات
المحيطه بكوبيانس وذلك نتيجه القصف
المتواصل سواء كان عبر المدفعيه الص واريخ
او المسيرات وهذا ما اشار اليه وتحدث عنه
حاكم الذي قال بان القصف ادى الى سقوط
مجموعه كبيره من القتلى والجرحى هذه عينه
عن القصف وهو يمتد في كافه ارجاء هذه
المدينه